after weeks of increasing coronavirus
cases deaths are rising at a faster pace
and
faster pace rather in many parts of the
country three of the worst hit states
that's california
texas and florida have each recorded
their highest
daily death tolls yet and there is
growing evidence that the surge is
linked
to the reopenings tony yeah and much of
america is pushing ahead with those
reopenings and there's no bigger symbol
of that than disney world which will
reopen its doors to the general public
tomorrow
and that of course is in florida where
according to the new york times average
daily cases have jumped nearly
1400 percent since the state reopened
dr anthony fauci is giving the u.s poor
marks for its response to the crisis
and that prompted fresh criticism of him
from president trump
when you compare us to other countries
i don't think you can say we're doing
great i mean
we're just not dr fauci's a nice man but
he's made a lot of mistakes they've been
wrong about a lot of things including
face masks maybe they're wrong maybe not
but a lot of them said don't wear a mask
don't wear a mask and now they're saying
wear a mask
so a lot of a lot of mistakes were made
of course the president himself has been
criticized for refusing to wear a mask
and amid all of this the country is also
short
of critical supplies including covid
tests
maria virial is at a testing site in
edinburgh texas maria good morning
what's it look like where you are
well good morning tony the state opened
this surge testing site because right
now in this area they are seeing
an increase in the number of coveted
positive cases and hospitalizations as
well
it is free to come here and over the
last few days thousands of people have
lined up right now the national guard is
setting up behind me this place doesn't
even open until eight in the morning and
already we've seen
cars lined up ready to take advantage
the number of coronavirus patients
hospitalized in texas
has quadrupled in the last month to
nearly ten thousand
the covered 19 virus in the city
quite frankly in the state is out of
control and what we do today
and over the next few weeks is critical
in the heart hit rio grande valley the
largest hospital system
says they are near capacity another
state with rising numbers
california which reported its highest
cova death toll thursday
los angeles officials are considering
another state home order if
hospitalizations don't fall
in arizona inpatient hospitalization hit
a record high
there are only 181 icu beds left in the
state
in a little over two weeks the state's
cases have more than doubled
the virus is widespread and the more
activity that is happening in our
economy
the more the spread will continue more
than two thousand arizonans have died
including 65 year old marco kiza my dad
was my
biggest fan he was so proud of me he was
the first person
that i can remember loving his daughter
kristen wrote a letter to the governor
saying his decision to lift the
stay-at-home order in may
gave her father a false sense of
security
why was it important for you to call the
governor out
these you know we can ask people to make
the right choices
left and right but folks in times of
crisis
turn to our leaders to send clear
messages about what to do
i believe that my father was robbed
of life and that his death was
preventable
what upsets her most is that he died
alone
i don't think that anybody should have
to go through what i've been going
through and i would not wish this upon
my worst enemy
back here in texas 39 of the people who
have contracted the virus
are hispanic and the age group the
largest age group with the highest
number of confirmed cases
is 30 to 39 year olds
medea thank you very very much